oh my God
hi I love you thank you touching you
into Mr Wayne no please don't stop
so you're saying you could travel back
in time
good Bruce I can fix things I can save
people
save my mom I can save your parents
all right
we can also destroy everything
I love you too so how was it this week
how's school Google was good
oh
this is mad trippy dude this is
catastrophic
this world must die
I'm not gonna lose there again
Scott Clark my name is Cara I will help
you
interesting groups want some help
wait he's Batman
you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
we're in unguarded territory
what happened what do we do we try not
to die
are you ready ready let's go
[Music]
we have fancy friends
Joe who's an Uber exec